now uh welcome everybody to another
ideas that matter conversation I have
here my colleague and and friend Donald
Robertson who
um among he's the founder of the new
Plato's Academy located in Greece in
Athens and we're going to talk about
that he's also one of the founding
members of what is eventually become
modern stoicism and there's a whole
backstory that maybe we'll start out
with that has some things that I even
didn't know about it having just joined
in 2016 myself so that goes back further
than that he's also a practicing
psychotherapist doing uh if correct me
if I'm wrong but your main modality is
cognitive behavior therapy but I think
you've done some other training as well
and author of a number of books we're
going to talk about uh
new slash old Book Project in here
somewhere as well but you might know him
from how to think like a Roman Emperor
fairly recently one and then verissimus
a graphic novel which was a
collaboration with Anon blanking on his
his name I remember the Frog about what
is the What is the illustrator
that's right yeah yeah beautiful uh book
about Marcus Aurelius his times his life
smuggling some stoic philosophy in there
to to get people into it so Donald
thanks so much for coming on
um tell us about the back history of
modern stoicism slash stoicism today
slash stoic week because you brought up
something in earlier conversation that I
didn't even know about that as somebody
who's been involved in it for years yeah
uh well let me think what was other
um just over a decade ago I think it was
I think it's yeah
um and I'd already written a book about
stoicism like called the philosophy of
CPT
and I was doing stoicism
do you know I was mainly speaking about
stoicism at Psychotherapy conferences
and on training with therapists and
stuff right and I'd put some stuff
online like I'd made an audio recording
of the view from above
and what was at the same time in Exeter
Chris Gill Professor uh Cresco who's
professor of ancient for extra had a
bunch of postgraduate students I believe
trying to live like Galen for a week and
they were trying to implement ancient
Roman Health Care advice but diet and
exercise and sleep and stuff like that
um
is some kind of uh experiment and the
students I believe found the audio
recording that I'd done of the view from
above and listened to it and thought hey
we could be doing live Marcus it really
is for me because Galen was Marcus
aurelius's
um Court physician
and so they started doing that and then
Chris
thought yeah we could do like love like
Marcus earliest week and he got some
funding to do a lot of Workshop in
Exeter and I Jules Evans Tim labone
and John Salos and some other people
went and met Chris and
by the brainstorming session of which
there's a video on the internet and we
decided to run the c-learning course
annually based on stoic week and we had
the court starts in conferences we
thought it would be a one-off thing and
then we got a lot of media attention in
most of the British newspapers and the
BBC Radio and stuff and it grew and it
grew and it grew and it turned into like
a regular fixture whereby we'd have
story corn every year and we'd run the
stoic week every year and and then over
time
uh within really a few years yourself
and massmo palucci and and various other
people got involved in stoicism
you know I mean Crisco was into stoicism
before it was cool
yeah
and there was only a few like it wasn't
cool cool at that point I don't
distinctly remember
um you know Lemmy yeah more ahead people
uh people used to laugh because when he
was hanging out with all like you know
these the younger generation of rockers
and all that let me say I can remember a
time before rock and roll existed
and they'd be like no so it's like
that's the first one he's like yeah I
remember yeah you know like skiffle and
stuff like that like the rock and roll
wasn't a thing really
um
I hadn't taken off and uh and I remember
I told you when stoicism the only books
on it were academic right it's big
university professors it was a real
Niche subject undergraduates didn't
really study it and then you know
somehow it suddenly started to become
popular and it really reignited it was
the internet
um was the kind of catalyst for like
people were waiting to it was waiting to
happen in a way in the internet kind of
allowed it to happen so we put this
course on mine uh it was Cresco
that kind of organized and people
started doing hundreds thousands and
thousands of people have done it I think
at one point we estimated about 20 000
people had done story week over this
last decade or so and uh that was how
that whole thing kind of took off
that's actually I think how I got uh
connected to the modern stoicism
organization it was through doing the
stoic week course uh because there used
to be a lot of forums in it where people
would chat back and forth and yeah
yeah that was quite quite uh interesting
so Galen uh who would have known now
actually I want to ask you about
something I was also surprised to hear
you say that the view from above
um audio recording is a guided
meditation essentially that that was out
there before that that's a sales thing
yeah what Drew you to to produce that in
the first place what was it reading
Marcus and then saying oh this could be
useful it's actually pretty specific I
it started off thinking basically all
right long story but maybe I need to
back up a little bit I did my first
degree in philosophy right but I was
reading Freud and stuff like that and I
wanted to be a psychotherapist and then
my Master's Degree was an
interdisciplinary center for the study
of philosophy and Psychotherapy and I
thought philosophy Psychotherapy try and
combine them together what I should do
is get Freud and combine it with
Heidegger or something like that okay
right so I spent a couple of years
trying to do that and and you know how
you sometimes you talk yourself out of
something the more you study yeah well
hey so the deeper I got into studying
Freud and the program study in Heidegger
and Jean-Paul Sartre like the more I I
thought this is kind of cool but
actually my main objection to it was the
apart from the lack of evidence for
clinical outcomes it was massively
overly complicated in a sense you know
your average man in the street
um 15 year old socially excluded school
kid or whatever is there's quite a gulf
between them and Heidegger or you know
soccer is being in nothingness or
something right yeah and then I kind of
discovered cognitive behavioral therapy
and I saw immediately all the references
to stoicism and those books and I
thought cool let's combine these two
things
um let's start again like pick a
different Psychotherapy and a different
philosophy and combine them and so I've
set about surveying all the literature
Guided by Pierre Hadoop
there was something strange about as
well he had surveyed all the spiritual
exercises right yeah that you could find
and as a psychotherapist reading this
um I thought I was telling the pages
Greg do you ever like start reading a
book you're working your way through and
you get like halfway through and you
think any minute now surely he's going
to mention the fact that all of these
contemplative practices that the Jazz
did and whatnot are obviously similar to
things that we do in Psychotherapy today
yeah and I thought maybe maybe that's
what the last chapter's about well
that's probably an opinion like a kind
of like you know like a a chapter at the
end
it's looking after four or something
maybe you wrote another one he's never
mentioned in the entire book like he
somehow goes through all of these
spiritual and psychological exercises
and at no point does he ever think maybe
people do this today and well I mean did
you think that has something to do with
the French psychoanalytic establishment
of his time because it was so rigid you
know
um it was yeah you did it this way and
if you did anything else they would
censure you as opposed to like what was
going on in Britain or America or other
places where it was more pluralistic
Psychotherapy is very different in
different countries and if you said to
him some I mean imagine if you spoke to
Pierre hadul about Psychotherapy he
would think what do you mean like
Jacques lacan and those guys yeah yeah
why because that got to do with what I'm
talking about or like kind of tenuously
yeah um but they don't really use
visualization exercises and the kind of
cognitive but he as he he doesn't to any
indication of being familiar with
cognitive therapy at all so to me it was
obvious to compare these two things I
took Hado
and I went through the stoics and other
stuff and uh I kind of started I I'm a
systematizer you know I catalog things
yeah and so I went through trying to
make a list like how many different
psychological interventions are there
other visual ones behavioral ones
cognitive ones well how would we
classify them and group them together
and I thought most of these have some
kind of parallel in modern therapy
mainly I found them in CBT yeah
um just as it happened you know uh you
did you did later discover and I mean
certainly by the time that we were in
Toronto because you were telling me
about it then a turn of the century
French yeah what would you call them not
he he wasn't a psychoanalyst he was
certainly a psychotherapist and he was
doing things that you were saying
they're clearly indebted to stoic
philosophy uh this never came again like
well let me uh let me finish the first
story and let me come back and talk
about that guy yeah yeah
so I was like most of these things
therapists do that's cool and so we can
explore the relationship and I thought
but there's something here that we don't
do
right and it struck me as first of all
like if there's something that the
stoics were doing a lot of that we don't
do
maybe we could be doing it because we
share so much common ground with them
like we've just missed us and there's
something that's maybe a little bit
tricky to explain but when you go really
deep into a subject and when you're
looking at a lot of research and you
know you've got a lot of clinical
practice and stuff sometimes you can
look at something and just go you know
it passes the smell test or whatever you
think immediately this looks this looks
like it would work yeah hey you know we
don't know until we do some research on
that but this isn't a crazy idea like I
mean if Psychotherapy by the way there
are lots of one thing we have no short a
job is crazy ideas right in the field of
psychotherapy and philosophy too yeah
but occasionally you think something you
think this View from Above thing
I and I this has been my experience of
explaining it to other people like
everyone agrees with me on this one
right so I saw and I immediately thought
this is this is a plausibility around it
right out the gate and before we even do
a research about it and it's a very
appealing because one of the
difficulties in modern research and
Psychotherapy and one of the problems
with psychonalysis is that it was hard
to do research on because you can't say
you know come and sit on this couch five
nights a week and tell me about your
dreams and we'll do that for five years
and we'd like to do brain Imaging on you
at the same time yeah or we're gonna get
like hundreds of people to do this in
the psychology department and can I like
you know measure the outcome it's
difficult to do any research on
traditional psychoanalysis because of
the way that it worked but the view from
above you're like oh my God like it's
kind of like love it for say in a way
for research because you think not only
is it really clear what the process is
here it's expanding your awareness and
you know yeah we could explain this in
the back of a postcard that says
straightforward the concept
um
clearly it's self-evident that it has
some kind of psychological effect we
don't know if it's good or bad or what
the concept but it definitely does
something yeah like exposure are we
honest right so that we can measure it
it's got a kind of plausibility about it
for a number of reasons there's plenty
of research that shows that when people
are emotionally distressed they tend to
narrow the scope of their attention so
hey what happens if you do the opposite
like this is plausible but also it's
unlike psychoanalysis and many other
therapies it's just a scripted process
you could just write uh oh and so that
allows you to standardize the delivery
right you go oh my God we don't even
need a therapist we could just do an
audio recording and tell everyone to
listen to it and then measure how they
responded to it right so I thought I
need to show this to people and so I
remember I can remember the first time I
stood up Greg that sounds like a you
know that sounds like a Shaggy Dog story
or something right but I it's true I
don't remember the first time I said I
used to teach Psychotherapy so I stood
up in front and it was great because I
had quite a lot of guinea pigs I so I'd
stand up
and they'd say oh what nonsense is it
going to come out with today right and I
think you remember you you guys remember
I was telling you all about stoicism and
they'd be like well yeah that sounds
kind of interesting and I'd say can I
get you to do an exercise and you just
tell me whether I'm crazy or not like
that seems like it might potentially be
useful in therapy and so I'd have like
30 people in a class
um or something I remember one's doing a
Psychotherapy conference there were like
two or three hundred people doing it but
then in the past with the students first
of all and I'd be like hey why don't we
just do this
and here's I'll write down a script you
guys can just read it to each other as
well and and I was I said what did you
think of it and they were all like yeah
this feels really nice
it looks like it should do something
like we could definitely do this with
clients in therapy it was no research we
don't know whether it like it's
therapeutic or not yet but yeah like I
mean and there isn't any research on
this number no there's no research on
this thing and they were like wow and
did you just make this up no people were
doing it all over the place in ancient
Greece and Rome like you know it's not
just the story it's the epicureans the
platonists the Latin poets talk about it
Ovid describes like something that's
that seems to be the same concept
basically so it struck me as very
strange this is a story worth telling
because it's one of those bizarre things
you think how come they were all in
Oneness and then somehow we completely
forgot about it and yeah I can explain
it to a bunch of psychotherapists and
the entire room are like
shouldn't we be doing some kind of
research on this yeah right now John
varvaki in uh Toronto in the psychology
department uh his understanding is doing
some research and related things and I
believe other people have started in you
know in Psychology departments have
started to to look into
but uh I made a recording also and I put
it online and it it that's why it was
the first thing Greg because okay I I
thought this stands out immediately to
me is something that's plausible and yet
has been more or less completely
forgotten now there's going to be some
pairs in out there that says
in an obscure 1970s book and
Psychotherapy right yeah no one's read
some guy does something that's tenuously
similar and I agree right probably but
for sure most psychotherapists that I
know and like mainstream cognitive
behavioral therapy or whatever we're not
doing anything that really resembled
that with their clients and yet as soon
as I told them about it the player I can
see myself doing that on the clients
it's not really struck a chord with me
and that's why
um it became sort of like in a book at
first that got people interested in
storesism and also if the problem would
be how do you get people to put stoicism
in practice well this is a really easy
way to do it all you have to do is
listen to the recording
and follow along and visualize and yeah
yeah
I was I was thinking of something as you
were talking about this um you know it
is the view from above and as you lead
people through it there it's beginning
at you know ground level and then if I
remember right because it's been a while
since I've listened to it you imagine
they you have them imagine like Rising
through the roof and then you know
looking down and seeing everything and
and this is coming from Marcus
um in his meditations and I was
wondering so I mean you mentioned so
when people become stressed or you know
they're they're having troubles they
tend to focus
narrowly not inward necessarily but just
on on what actually it could be either
right okay
so you've got health anxiety Greg and
that's your big thing you're going to
become very concerned with focusing on
your heart right right right you're
occupied with it but if it's social
anxiety you might become very
preoccupied with people in the audience
or yeah you know even if you're worrying
and it's all in your head you might
become very so narrowly focused on your
imaginings about what could go wrong in
the future that you don't notice what's
happening around you so here's here's my
question about that yeah
um
historically it is it's a view from
above in the meditation of the view from
above does it need to be I suppose it
does need to be from above otherwise you
can't get the vantage point right but
does it have to have the like rising up
into the air it could just be okay I
think it could just be an expanding
spatially and chronologically or it
could be oh well that's actually another
important point I mean typically we
think about it as primarily spatial but
Marcus does really talk about think
about the eons past and how they were
doing exactly the same nonsense as we're
doing now and
um so
would you would you I mean this is just
a total like brainstorm would you put
together another similar meditation
based on that that has people thinking
yeah exactly
you could that'd be awesome I mean we so
then sometimes in therapy we do things
that I think are fundamentally related
to that okay look a little bit different
um so I think a good
evidence-based psych therapist would
also understand
that
um
being selective well let me here's that
this is where we get this you're gonna
like this this is the intersection
between philosophy and psychology right
yeah um and there's often intersections
between these two subjects I think
people kind of Overlook in a way they
don't think about how they they might
interact
so one of them is
um I guess it's a philosophical point
about psychology
when we think about events right
how do we decide
what the time parameters are for the
beginning middle and end of the event
that we're thinking about
so for example if I think about what I
had for breakfast today yeah I think
about maybe sitting down
and eating it and then getting up at the
end when I leave
but I could broaden that if I chose to
do so and include the process of
preparing her right well I and you know
maybe I could include the whole of my
morning if I chose to now when people
worry about things or get depressed
about things Greg
they we're often engaged what's
interesting is when we engage in an
activity we make choices and we don't
even realize that we're making those
choices because we've never thought
about them as choices so when people
worry
right they're choosing the beginning
middle and end of the sequence of events
that they worry about
but they don't have exactly they don't
exact control or free choice over that
because it doesn't even occur to them
that they could do it differently
worry about losing your job but you know
I'm concerned about I'm losing my job
right
how when you're going over that in your
mind how do you decide what constitutes
the beginning of the event and the end
of it what happens if you just broaden
it like um just a few so anxious about
the idea of losing my job uh applying
for loads of other ones and then finding
a new job
uh if you were to expand the chronology
of it you can think well hang on a
minute now then it seems more like a
rounded process that has good bets and
bad bits in it and opportunities as well
as threats you know and the ultimate
version of course would be to picture
your entire life or the entire history
of the human race or the whole history
but you don't even need to do that is
even if you expanded what you normally
think about
to a certain degree it would change the
way you feel about it because you would
be taking another stimuli
um and this is a very familiar concept
actually in in ancient literature
would you have to do that in such a way
that
um and I am kind of struggling for the
right words for this where you're
looking at it realistically because I
could imagine somebody
um projecting ahead something you know
let's say they're very dismal about I
don't know it could be jobs it could be
relationships it could be even just the
process of getting old and they have
kind of this imaginary bad thing that is
that they're headed towards
um but like you said you know if you if
you look at things more broadly you can
see there's good points there's bad
points you know you you actually have
some
some measure of input into making things
good or bad right
um so what you're talking about I think
is kind of like catastrophizing or what
which is typical right so you're going
to spiral and you just imagine things
getting worse and worse and worse and
worse then I mean actually I think
when you attempt to expand
the time perspective deliberately that
becomes less likely to happen and people
I think will naturally think about it
more realistically also if you do
anything you do do you know what's his
name Marcel Duchamp said if I take a
urinal
and uh uh art gallery
it becomes a work of art
right now that's also true if you take
some if you take people's worries and
anxieties and replicate them in a
therapy Consulting room it's like taking
a urinal and put it in an art gallery in
the tape modern or somewhere like that
they experience it differently
experiencing in a very different context
for a bunch of reasons right but for
sure they do so you don't usually tend
to see this catastrophic spiral when we
do that for some reason but it could
happen so you might want to see a look
yeah of course deliberately
um you'd want to ask yourself to picture
the the consequences of an event
realistically and you're coping ability
realistically and so on I think we maybe
come back to that when we talk about
some other uh these techniques but there
are things that people do spontaneously
but they could also be instructed to do
them deliberately and one of them would
be adopting a realistic attitude
um like just like you're saying yeah it
is it is important
um there's other things that would
mitigate against the catastrophizing
apart from the fact that you're just
doing it in a Consulting room and so the
fact you're doing it in a different
environment and someone's instructing
you will mean that you're probably doing
it with greater self-awareness than you
would normally do it like because it's
an artificial environments and they're
thinking a little bit more than normal
about how you're doing it and also
therapist is asking you questions like
why are you pulling that weird face when
you're doing it and stuff like that and
now he's making yourself conscious in a
way that you are normally right that
changes the whole recipe yeah um but
also a therapist
and this is another side issue but it's
uh and maybe something we would come
back to when people worry they usually
it's usually mainly variable
um and it tends to be vague abstract and
consist of a lot of questions of course
this happens what if that happens how am
I going to cope right but if yeah
visualize you're visualizing stuff
immediately forces you to make it more
concrete and you tend to react
differently so usually you'll start to
engage more reality testing
um and you don't spiral into worrying in
the same way if you make it more of a
visual process basically interesting
yeah so you're you're kind of giving
yourself more to do right by visualizing
as well yeah um and there's other stuff
that's that's correct I actually you
know I won't be about I'll try because
there's so many things we could say
things we could go off here I'll try and
get right to the core of this we know
one of them there's time there are
thousands of studies inside therapy
we've been doing research side therapy
for 150 years believe it or not since
the middle of the 19th century right we
come back that brings us back to what
you were saying a minute ago about what
went wrong with Freud and like how come
he wasn't doing any research but they
we've been doing all those research we
know that the most robustly established
technique and the entire field of
psychotherapy research is a behavior
therapy intervention called exposure
therapy all right yeah yeah and I saw it
was kind of knowing about it since at
least the 1920s there were studies on it
but it didn't become big until about the
60s right and it's so well established
the we use it as a benchmark comparison
for other techniques now right so
receptors oblique we know this works so
that we can just compare it to this new
thing that we're we want to test right
when you've got a really solid
intervention you know for sure it does
something and then you come up with some
other thing you can compare them now
it's a it's useful to use it as a kind
of gold standard or a benchmark so it's
a chemotherapy goes standard in a way so
exposure therapy is based on a mechanism
that we sometimes call there's different
names there's multiple names for
everything in the therapy field but we
often we call it emotional habituation
an emotional habituation
is the fact physiological facts
basically the anxiety will Abate
naturally or wear off through repeated
prolonged exposure to the stimulus under
appropriate conditions basically so if
you have a cap for br
and I put you in a room with a bunch of
cats the easiest way to explain it is
you your heart rate will probably almost
double within less than five seconds
but what happens next
well you'll have a very strong urge to
leave the room yeah why would you know
with a cloud the dust like Zoom like out
the door but if you don't do that and by
the way what would be the main reason
for you not doing that would be if you
were a child and your parent was with
you and they were saying just hang in
there buddy or if a therapist was
fulfilling a similar role
uh and seeing hang in there left your
own devices you're probably going to
want to to leave but if someone else is
coaching you and encouraging you to
remain in the situation what's going to
happen next
what happened to your heart rate
what should decline but slowly right
yeah how long is that going to take
I don't know uh it varies
yeah I mean I would I would tend to
think it would probably still remain
elevated so long as the thing is in the
room but taper down right yeah I mean it
might take anything from like five ten
minutes to half an hour in some cases
yeah yeah like for an extreme severe
phobias or something like maybe I don't
know maybe take an hour or something
right okay some very severe anxiety
disorders but it could go down within
five minutes right what happens if you
do that every day for a week
much quicker right yeah well first of
all your anxiety doesn't go quite high
and it'll Define more quickly and after
a while it'll extinguish permanently
like phobia there's not a high relapse
rate for phobias that you've heard
exposure therapy for some psychological
problems go away and then come back
again other ones are usually like one
and done so generally phobias uh one of
the easiest things to treat you have a
90 success rate in treating phobias with
exposure therapy uh often the standard
would be in about three hours of
treatment so relatively short space it
says we've nailed this right yeah like
if you have a simple four but we pray we
know how to cure it believe it for all
the Psychotherapy seems like a bit of a
mess as a science like and and Science
in its infancy there are certain things
that we nailed in the 1970s as sometimes
you know people sometimes put it we but
in the 1970s we'd forget about how to
treat phobias with a very high degree of
success yeah um it's a very because it's
a very very simple mechanism right so
definitely you asked we were talking
about the difference between worrying
and catastrophizing
and visualizing stuff right and you in
addition to going in a room full of cats
you could watch a video of cats if you
had a severe phobia or you might shut
your eyes and visualize cats it and
that'll evoke anxiety but also it will
trigger this mechanism of habituation so
if you have a cat phobia and you just
visualize cats for like 15 minutes 20
minutes each day by your anxiety level
your anxiety will wear off you have to
do it for long enough right uh but if
you do it for long enough and repeatable
enough your anxiety or off now crucially
that doesn't happen
when you're worrying about stuff if
you're verbally going around in circles
it never gets old worries never go
really but if you visualize them you
habituate so there's a theory let's get
let's do a real deep dive there's a
there's a psychologist
an American psychologist I think is
retired now called Tom berkovic and he
was the one of the world's leading
authorities in the psychology of worry
and he's a CBT researcher and berkovic
forwarded it on the basis of his
research something known as the
cognitive avoidance model of worry okay
and it starts off with a paradox which
is that people that have severe worry
and we're talking about pathological
worry that you'd find in what we call
generalized anxiety disorder or Gad so
in clinical research we've confined
people with very severe versions of
everyday problems everyone worries but
people with GED have very severe
pathological worry
um if you ask them from zero to ten how
anxious do you feel when you're worrying
about 10 out of 10 100 very severe right
yeah okay that's cool so could you shut
your eyes and just worry all that crazy
okay and you can replicate you can feel
the work yeah yeah super anxious right
ah could we measure your heart rate skin
of galvanometer respiration stuff like
that well just bun all this kind of
stuff that you have in a lie detector
right we can wear you up as much
machines and measure things now
something real happens when you do that
Greg the researchers didn't really
expect to find and that is that when
people are having a worry episode we've
got Gad often the heart rate doesn't go
up
play and you think well hey I thought
you were freaking out and you had very
severe anxiety if you're a cat phobic
and I threw a cat at you I'm pretty sure
your heart rate's going to go through
the roof your heart rate's going to
double feel like you're running really
really hard right yeah the same people
with panic attacks so their heart rate
shuts off that's what anxiety looks like
it's pretty straightforward but people
with pathological worrying will Rapport
intense levels of anxiety but they don't
show the physiological signs of it with
one exception they show increased
muscular attention interestingly right
so they'll be tensing the shoulders and
throwning and stuff like that yeah but
otherwise they're not really showing you
symptoms so bark effect this is really
weird
they really believe they're anxious and
they feel anxious and they're suffering
from anxiety but they're not showing
physiological signs of anxiety and it's
a pretty straightforward thing so what I
offer is going on here and he came to
the conclusion that worrying seems to
perhaps be better understood as a a form
of avoiding contact with the things that
trigger anxiety
so things that would make you your heart
rate shoot through the roof if you
actually saw them are experienced and
you'd feel real visceral physiological
symptoms of anxiety if you worry about
them
you're dealing with them but you're kind
of conning yourself into thinking that
you're addressing the problem well
actually in a sense avoiding it because
you're thinking when you worry about
things in a vague and Abstract manner
yeah and your attention usually drops
around from one aspect to another and
doesn't settle in any aspect long enough
so worry is a way of duping yourself
into thinking you're facing problems I
mean facts in a sense you're avoiding
them does that mean that worry is itself
like a sort of high level coping
mechanism yeah but it's not healthy
cooking it's a maladaptive yeah yeah
emotional coping strategy and I
something that helps confirm that is if
you work with people with severe anxiety
after a while it becomes obvious when
you're talking you talk to them a lot
but worry what it looks like you dissect
it and stuff and you realize that a lot
of people that have pathological worry
you know what they don't call it
worrying they call it something else oh
they call it they call it being prepared
preparing yeah yeah or they call it
problem solving yeah yeah anybody
but you're not problem solving you're
worrying about no I'm problem solving
wait I just happened to do it in my
problem solving in the middle of the
night or
yeah
they could justify going on the internet
and looking up uh information as like
you know doing research as well then
right yeah is that part of it yeah
that's something that they'll do right
so they may not even see it as worrying
and another interesting thing is if you
ask people who have pathological
worrying from they'll tell you how awful
it is and you know they're getting
really anxious and stuff but if you say
from zero to 100 how helpful is your is
your how strongly do you believe that
worrying helps you prepare for example
they're often the play 90 look pretty
high yeah but I feel like I mean I hate
worrying it's driving me crazy but I
have this ambivalence towards of it
because I feel like I have to do it if I
didn't worry I wouldn't be prepared for
the problem right so they you know
they're addicted
to this maladaptive coping strategy
which they perceive as preparing a
problem solving but actually it's not
helpful and it's making them miserable
interesting
but actually what we've done what you've
unintentionally done is segued into
discussion about premeditation malorum
as well like before we do that though
the and I forgot his name the French
psychotherapist
and he's called Paul Dubois okay oh he's
Swiss interests and so francophone
though or yeah it was francophone and he
was a psychotherapist if I remember
rightly to a famous author it may have
been Bruce
like he had he was a celebrity that he
was one of the first celebrity
psychotherapists before okay learn all
that right and he was a famous guy and
he was famous in the field of
psychotherapy he was well known in
Europe he was Freud's biggest rival and
he wasn't alone there were many people
that practiced what they called rational
Psychotherapy or not to be confused with
what Walter matri Chuck and Alberto
right completely different thing yeah
but they called it rational side therapy
and sometimes they call it persuasion
psych therapy and they would there were
many books on it which are all out of
credit because everyone lost interest in
them right and
they they did this therapy DuBois was
really into Seneca
funnily enough Alice barely mentioned
Seneca he's really into Epictetus right
but Dubois is the way around here like
Seneca he prescribed reading seneca's
letters to his clients as homework
assignments he talks to them again
interestingly he talks to them about
stoic determinism which he thinks is he
puts for the pretty good keys for being
a therapeutic concept and that's an
aspect of stoicism that in CBT they're
no longer interested in
instead of
passage five and then herodian that says
it's not things that upset us but rather
our opinions about them yeah why is much
more interested in passage one of them
that says some things are up to us and
other things are not that that cost me a
control as people call it today and he
saw that as being the most fundamental
concept that he was deriving from from
stoicism
and you know he uh he basically also
referred to his technique his Socratic
questioning and he mentioned Jennifer
and Socrates about as well
um so he's very explicitly influenced by
ancient philosophy and then everyone
forgot about this guy he was a big deal
back in the day and
and they're they haven't forgot about
him because he made a mistake
uh he failed to write a book about the
Psychopathology of sexual perversions
and to go around American universities
uh with slideshows or whatever giving
lectures
um on anal sex masturbation by
bisexuality all the stuff that Freud
loved talking about yeah yeah
um and so Freud that people are going to
be losing their minds in France and
Brazil before he's very popular if we
here if they hear us saying they're
sacral and stuff Freud partly became a
sensation because he talked a lot about
sex
do you want to have sex with your mum
and you're afraid your dad's going to
come straight you and today he would
have been all over social media he would
he would have millions of followers on
Twitter because he was saying
Sensational stuff yeah yeah and in the
same way you know if you want to go in
The Joe Rogan show you can't say
um there's a nice measured approach to
things yeah you've got to say all of
your problems are caused by your fear
that your father's gonna castrate you or
something that sounds crazy and then Joe
Rogan with big you in a flash of you
know in the back of an island yeah play
and he did you get millions of views
right and Freud was kind of like that in
a way he became a sensation because he
went to America like and you know
because he was saying
these contentious things and everyone
forgot but jabois who was like you I
just think your anxieties are caused by
these false beliefs that you have and
mistaken opinions about yourself and you
know you're focusing too much on things
on you know Common Sense stuff right and
maybe we just need to wear up the
evidence and find other perspectives
that are more practical and yada yada
nah that's boring well I'm not
interested in that so everyone forgot
that they'd already discovered cognitive
therapy for about half a century and
then Albert Ellis now the funny thing
this is a bit of kind of Chet chat but
it's kind of cool like Albert Ellis now
Academia is full of jerks who
rate books that are clearly derivative
right why and they don't happen to
mention and the reason that they're
massive jerks is that when you're a
student you absolutely have it drummed
into you that you have to acknowledge
your sources right yeah yeah but a lot
of professors don't do that and a lot of
the guys that we're studying because we
study Heidi going he's not really
telling you where he's got half of these
ideas from like you know there's other
thinkers that preceded him that he's
borrowing a lot of these Concepts from
um Albert Ellis I always admired because
he was one of those guys who was the
opposite and he would happily tell you
all of these obscure writers that he was
borrowing ideas from right other
psychologists don't do that they go I'm
a genius I just completely invented this
entire therapy and you're like dude this
is just Gestalt therapy well you just
called it something else like you're not
fooling anyone right but that happens
over and over again in philosophy and
psychology like people reinvent the
Beyond pass off as their own Ellis
didn't do that but the one guy he never
credited was Paul Dubois until later and
I believe it and he and he'd read him he
hadn't written no he hadn't read him I
believe in Alice Ellis said I I
discovered this guy later and I'd never
I'd never heard of him and I I think
he's telling the truth I think he just
genuinely never held on this guy and
Ellis was a massive nerd about the
history of psychotherapy and even
despite that he's still never really he
delved into this subject because most of
the books were over print and this is
before the internet yeah and now being
able to print
um was the stuff translated into English
but it wasn't widely read by that point
and I I just think yeah you know no one
was talking about it anymore it's all
sword because there was a point where it
and then people in America were doing it
as well yeah you know oh go ahead they
were I would say that this approach was
around for maybe half a century
but it can afford a curve uh it had its
Heyday maybe in 1910 1920s
thereabouts and then it gradually kind
of faded out until there's a few guys
hanging at all time us hanging on still
doing it and it sort of fizzled out
um but I don't I genuinely think Alice
didn't realize
you know I'm I'm struck the reason I
asked you about translation is because
I've noticed something
um with some of the people who I've I've
done work on or I've translated there's
often this assumption and it's a very
circular thing that well if uh if it's
not translated then nobody's really
interested in it so I don't have to pay
attention to it so then nobody
translates it and then it just
perpetuates itself but I mean it can
happen with things that are translated
if there's not a critical mass of people
who are referencing something there's
this assumption that I think a lot of
people in Academia tend to have that if
it was important people would be talking
about it so I'm not going to read the
stuff and then they never you know if
they're getting anything it's usually
glosses not the actual text which is
much richer you know I half agree with
you because I think and some of the
other main guys had been translated from
where I understand had already been
translated into English but I think
there were probably a lot of other
people doing it and those one place in
particular Greg yeah there were a lot of
people doing this and nobody in America
was reading it and that plane there was
a place
a what a big place where they wouldn't
touch Freud with a barge pool where is
that the Soviet Union oh right right
yeah they were yeah all into Marxism and
they were like well they saw Marxism as
fundament at that time ironically
because in in France like in the 60s 70s
marxists got really interested in
psychoanalysis but the Soviets were like
we're not touching the stuff of the
barge people psychology it's total
pseudoscientific nonsense right out the
gate they were like this is
pseudoscience like it's a form of
idealism as they put it yeah by which
they meant it's not rooted in any kind
of physical
um science we are much more interested
they were doing research like proper
laboratory studies on Psychotherapy 1910
1920 you know measuring basic
physiological measures that we've been
talking about doing measuring the
relaxation response platinov was one of
the main Soviet researchers the his work
wasn't translated until the 1950s I
think into English
but he was doing stuff at the start of
the century and they were using rational
persuasion techniques combined with
um hypnosis and physio relaxation
training for biofeedback and stuff all
that kind of stuff had nothing to do
with Freud like and they were Freud who
wouldn't know a research study like if
he beat him over the head with one like
he never did any Shredder research on
Psychotherapy in his entire career and
sometimes people think we didn't start
doing reception Psychotherapy until the
1960s well that's not true yeah yeah
people were doing experiments on it and
outcome studies clinical studies like
the start of the century in the Soviet
Union why but for some reason you know
Freud caught on in Europe and America
um and it eclipsed everything else it
became so big everyone forgot
about this other approval which you know
fizzle though accepts in the Soviet
Union where it carried on and then in
the some of that work was translated and
then in the 60s and 70s
we had this well really by the late mid
to late 50s
um we had the revolution in
Psychotherapy where people started
drawing much more on psychological
research and behaviorism and early yeah
cognitive psychology
and then you get CBT developing an LS
and back and all of those guys
well that's quite interesting so one of
the things we were going to talk about
was other practices and
[Music]
um I also I mean there were a few ideas
we were kicking around one is
limitations on them like not every
practice should necessarily be done by
everybody because it could have adverse
effects but I think we could also say
well you know practices have to be done
in a certain way too you can't just like
grab something off of some there's all
these lists of practices out there that
you see like in blogs and so we had
philosophical problem here as well okay
and it's an unusual look again at this
intersection between
Psychotherapy uh Clinical Psychology and
philosophy I think there are unusual
problems that no one ever discusses but
their cultural philosophical problems
yeah underlying this I'm gonna back
right up and then we'll come back into
like okay but basically there's an issue
here about the medical model
and how we conceptualize
these kind of techniques right
um
so for example
as a clinician or as a former clinician
I should say uh mainly an author now but
if you were doing certain psychological
techniques you do risk assessment with
your client and you definitely wouldn't
take somebody who has agrophobia and
panic attacks and get them to do real
breathing techniques
or get them to visualize really
anxiety-provoking things Yeah in our as
homeworks or a way that's kind of in a
way that's kind of uncontrolled right
because you may just trigger a panic
attack
now sometimes you might do something
similar on purpose but I mean you
wouldn't want to do it in a kind of
uncontrolled unpredictable way where you
might just traumatize a clients however
right so it's a philosophy don't written
but people do stuff like this in yoga
classes every day oh yeah right and
meditation passes right how well because
that's not Medical
right we don't think of it as being
medical intervention and so there's
always been this problem of where do you
draw the line
between Psychotherapy as a clinical
practice and other stuff like past the
one of the historical ones is pastoral
counseling
um careers coaching and stuff like
guidance counseling
um it's not clinical
um and yeah it's kind of similar it's
like there's an overlap between it and
Psychotherapy meditation classes
right yeah so there is no risk
assessment normally generally speaking
you you don't when you're going to a
yoga class
fellow uh uh an intake form there's no
like from a risk assessment usually you
can just turn up for class in any Town
set and set in the corpse posture flow
out your body realign your chakras and
breathe through your nostrils and stuff
like that if you have a panic attack the
instructor will just put oh gee what's
happening yeah you know generally
speaking but if you're a therapist you
think oh whoa we have before we do
anything we assess this client you know
and you might say what people usually
say then is they've got well your
client's Psychotherapy or have mental
health problems right but these are
normal people that go to yoga classes
and I would dispute that assumption yeah
actually the instructors too you know
yeah exactly kind of a mixed bag exactly
I think if they do any sort of risk
assessment it's not anything
psychological it would be well don't do
these postures because
injuries yeah exactly yeah and stuff but
not really psychological and I've seen
people freak out in yoga classes and
have panic attacks and at Buddhist
Retreats I've seen uh you know people
who are schizophrenic having oh yeah
like meltdowns and stuff but um we don't
think about it in the same way we apply
a different Paradigm to it it's not a
medical setting
um so there's things that as a therapist
we'd be maybe other people would see us
as being overly cautious about and some
say if I was getting a clients and
visualize stuff you know I I'd check
let's check that and be careful about it
you might think yeah but if someone did
a meditation class of some new age that
you know they didn't check any of these
things
um so maybe you guys are nannying your
clients too much and being overly
cautious or maybe those other yoga
classes meditation classes aren't being
cautious enough now I don't really have
the answer to that because it's a kind
of conflicting set of values and culture
that stems from two very different
paradigms that we're applying to the
process but there's a contradiction of
sorts there I feel
yeah and I mean I would say this can
extend to like self-help books or all
sorts of things where we're putting
ideas in people's hands and I do want to
come back to talking about you know
stoicism in particular because it is so
so popular and there's so many people
out there shooting videos blogging even
writing you know often self-publishing
books where they they make these very
big promises like well you just do these
10 things uh which derive from the
ancient stoics and and when we when you
look at it sometimes you know it's it's
it'll there'll be like a little passage
from Epictetus but it's mostly this
person writing their own thing yeah and
you and you think okay so some of these
things could actually be helpful but a
lot of these are like you said you're
saying
um but they they could have a terrible
impact on on people and actually we were
going to talk about visualization but I
actually I want to throw another one out
there with you so there's you know
there's a lot of people saying I kind of
worms no Greg yeah and I'm I'm cool with
that you know we'll pull that then we
might have to do another one
a bucket of worms well so you know the
the all the toughness
stoicism yeah things you know like uh
and you know so epic baby if you want to
be a real man
that's right yeah it tends to be much
more masculine oriented than anything
else
um but I you know I was thinking like
the people who take cold showers and
Advocate oh it changed my life you know
and epic she just doesn't say do that he
says you know take a little sip of cold
water and spit it out you know don't do
anything super extreme but there there's
a lot of people who seem to think well
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna be the exercise
stoic or I'm gonna be you know this
person and put my hands in cold water or
hot water or you know and it strikes me
that a lot of these people are okay if
they want to do that and screw their own
bodies up you know
um
that's not good but you know they're not
screwing anybody else up but when other
people like uncritically accept their
their points of view and then they think
well this is what what you know the
stoics did
um they can get into some you know some
serious trouble that way
um I mean not even all the cynics did
that you know we hear about like
imagination is doing that but krates
didn't do that sort of stuff you know
um
he's not really for everybody yeah maybe
there's there's a hidden head of that do
you know when he says that what it
reminds me of and when they say it
really just by as an aside really
reminds me of this idea of what they
call they call it
um
like Tantra and uh oh right right yeah
and they'll say well Tanta is kind of an
extreme Buddhist path and it's not for
everyone and it can be kind of dangerous
right it sounds to me when Equity is
talking about cynicism like he's saying
uh similar effect you know this can go
wrong and it's not it's not it can be
beneficial it could Excel yeah you're
training version but it also could go
down
um the wrong path but I think also
you're saying a combination of things
right I think in part what you're saying
is some Modern self-help advice might be
bad advice yeah right
some of it is maybe trading on stoicism
and perhaps not doing so in a very
accurate or informed way you know they
might be wrong or so arbitrarily
associating things with stoicism to give
some sort of credibility to what they're
doing there's another problem and it's
hard to explain I'll have a bash it's
articulating this anyway this is what
happens if you look too deeply into like
a subject for a long time you start to
say paradoxical things so I think the
bigger problem than these guys giving
bad advice is the fact that they're not
giving good advice if that makes sense
so I'll give you an example okay job and
Pearson or Andrew T or one of these guys
right but let's pick Jordan peels yeah
yeah I think there's some bad
psychological advice in John Peterson's
books and videos like in 12 rules
but the thing that stands out more to me
is the lack or absence of what I would
consider to be good
psychological advice for instance
there's no reference and it's very
striking to me
to the oh many people say that they feel
junkets and stuff resembles stoicism and
when I asked them about that and ask
them what they think the similarities
are they say well Peterson says you
should take to your room
and the stoics emphasize personal
responsibility but when I try and dig
deeper that seems to be the only
similarity they can put their finger on
and I think but are there any
self-improvement offers that don't
emphasize personal responsibility it's
kind of you know a common feature of
virtually all self-improvement more or
less so that doesn't seem like a very
strong connection to me and I think
obviously the main cycle one of the main
psychological pieces of advice the
stoics give is they're based on their
cognitive model of emotion they think
fear is an expectation if something bad
is going to happen you might be wrong
about that yeah you know the anger is
the belief that someone deserves to be
punished like they've done acted on you
may be wrong about that right so it's uh
once you go cognitive you you know you
can't go back because if you recognize
that your emotions are grounded in
beliefs then those beliefs might be true
or false right and it changes the whole
landscape of psychotherapy we call it
the cognitive Revolution and
Psychotherapy now weirdly although
Jordan Peterson is not only a clinical
psychologist but a professor of Clinical
Psychology in 12 rules at least he never
mentions this once and I'd like I just
said it changes the entire landscape of
self-help advice so he's right right
talking about an approach to
self-improvement that to me looks like
it would be more at home in the 1970s
like it's kind of completely ignores
what to me is the generally perceived
among evidence-based clinicians to be
the biggest advance in the whole field
and it has to do with taking personal
responsibility but not personal
responsibility for taking a room
personal responsibility for the beliefs
and attitudes that make you angry or
anxious or depressed in the first place
there's not a shred of that in his
ratings as far as I can see or if there
is it's pretty well buried behind a load
of other stuff so there's a lack of it
would be like
you know like somebody teaching you how
to be a car mechanic or how to be a chef
and and leaving out one of some really
basic essential piece of information
that everything else is based on you
know so that that seems odd to me yeah
yeah
um about a lot of self-help life
insurance the lack of reference to good
advice you're running around tidying
your room and stuff like that but you're
not if you went to see someone for CBT
the first thing they would say to you is
what are the thoughts that make you
upset
just like Epictetus said and other sorts
of true or false why are they rational
or irrational are they helpful or
unhelpful like okay what evidences are
for them what evidence is the against
them and we'd be doing cognitive therapy
like in in Peterson's book there's none
of that so he's met he leaves out the
main thing the most
evidence-based clinical psychologist
would actually be doing to treat
depression or anxiety which seems very
odd to me
um
so there's that but uh
there's a lot of bad advice no actually
let me kind of let me I'll segue from
that into
and again I think this is a
philosophical point I'm going to make
the say there's lots of different
emotional coping strategies or lots of
different you pick and choose take your
pick like you can go and punch a bag in
the gym you can drink a bottle of
whiskey you know you you can listen to
you can go and do yoga you can realign
your chakras you know you can Comfort
eat like there's about no different
Bunch away you're gonna have sex but
there's a bunch of ways that people try
to manage their emotional state
right I feel depressed or trying to play
computer games to distract myself from
that for a bit or whatever I'll go and
argue with people on the internet people
do things to cope with emotions like
they're driven to do it no
in doing that you have to have
assumptions about what your emotions
actually are what can a beast is anger
what does it look like
and one of the biggest problems I think
that faces Society is the
we the majority of people share a kind
of folk psychology as we sometimes put a
model of emotion which is ridiculously
naive and inaccurate
and we think of our emotions as being
kind of homogeneous almost like the
Blobs of energy like I've got this anger
I've got to say anxiety it's just a blob
of feeling that's kind of homogeneous it
builds up in me and it it you could also
sometimes yeah call it a hydraulic model
that builds up pressure and so people
like Andrew T to pick another one will
say I studied what Andrew take what
advice he gave people I was curious
about how to deal with emotions he
sounded to me like someone who's not
spent more than a couple of minutes
thinking about this question like which
is odd for a self-improvement guru right
so he said oh you you should repress or
should suppress the feelings sometimes
he says that and then other times he
cannot contradicts that and says he
thinks it's a bad idea and what you
should do is go to the gym and get out
of your system there so kind of
cathartic approach to emotional okay
um through physical exercises I mean
what what emotions is that supposed to
actually work for I mean traditionally
anger yeah go chop down a tree go to the
gym but I mean is that supposed to
actually work for sadness or fear or no
it doesn't really work object interacted
like that no it doesn't really work that
well for other things you know
Psychotherapy yeah I've tried to vein
anxiety and depression and regression
hypnosis is the main way Freud used to
do that he'd get people to regress back
to Childhood and remember horrible
things that happened and then busted the
tears the idea was that you'd get it all
out your system oh right so yeah they
called it the hydraulic model of emotion
so I thought it's all building up inside
you and just looking eating something
you might take a vomit of that makes you
throw up and get this bad stuff out of
your stomach he thought we can get out
of your mind by having you relive it and
express it and you know we now know that
that generally makes people worse or or
it doesn't help them that much
especially with anger a number of
studies that show that venting anger
actually makes people angrier than they
were to begin with but she'd think it
was common sense because otherwise you'd
think Mike Tyson
who vents his anger a lot
and punch bags and in the gym and stuff
yeah should be the calmest guy Mama
scare you for familiar life and like it
totally chilled out but boxers and you
know other people that are involved in
violence but so are not necessarily like
that right sometimes they're like a
coiled spring really to explode actually
you know in some cases it very it's
gonna happen less as a way of coping
with emotion same with boss 90 years
like if if you're always busting into
tears it doesn't get out of your system
if anything it potentially just makes
you more prone to bust out and it seals
in the future like if you're not if
you're not careful
so it's bad advice sometimes that these
guys are giving as well but that bad
advice stems from
a naive understanding of the nature of
emotion and there are a number of ways
in which the misunderstanding emotion
but one of them I think the main one is
the they don't recognize the goal of
cognition and emotion so I mean
Jordan Peterson says for example if a
woman rejects you
It's Perfectly Natural that you should
feel and he he's what he says is quite
bizarre he says it's natural that you
should feel like violent aggressive
emotions and kind of you know like even
have sort of Revenge fantasies and
things like that
and I thought you know the way that the
story actually used to explain this idea
and also I think this idea comes from
Socrates uh I believe
um they send both Plato and xenophon so
I think yeah we'll go back to the real
guy the real Socrates but Socrates would
say to people that other people feel the
same way
such simple questions and we'd ask that
a cognitive therapy like no I would have
thought it's common sense that unless
all you do is play computer games and
you don't have any friends right yeah if
if you've if you've got some friends
that are young guys you probably know at
least one of them that gets rejected
occasionally when he has to go out on a
date and he couldn't care less yeah like
water off the doctor that moves on to
the next person next next opportunity so
you'd think that simple Common Sense
observation would tell you everything
that you need to know that it's not
natural it's not essential to human
nature in any sense and in fact it's a
variable that's mediated by your
attitudes and values towards women
in which case you know
what you would probably want to do if
you get that angry is not to go invent
it in the gym or not to you know sit and
ruminate about how Society should be
different and women should have a
different status and blame the trigger
or blame the like uh the other person
but you might want to go away and think
wow what's the difference between me and
my buddy like why did I get enraged by
when a woman rejects me if I start on a
date he doesn't seem to care takes it in
a stride that guy why what difference is
there in our beliefs attitudes and
values the you know the socratic
questioning might be able to help with
yeah um there should be some kind of
process of self-questioning and that's
what we would normally do in in
cognitive therapy but these guys won't
go anywhere on the other
because
I think subtly what they're really about
is trading on some of these unhealthy
emotions
um I think it's fair to say that some
self-help gurus who weirdly
get into politics
or what they call politics yeah like are
spend an awful lot of time whipping up
fear and anger and Their audience right
right whereas normally a therapist what
we're trying to do is get people to kind
of Step Back From Fear and anger and
re-examine the causes of her right I
mean
something that comes to mind is would
you say that these people these
um whatever we want to call them Guru
types
yeah I mean they're also encouraging a
sort of continued dependency upon them
right I mean they're promising
Independence to these these guys and
it's largely guys that that are I'll
tell you exactly who what they are right
okay like the first time I came across
that guy Andrew Tate which is years ago
I thought
has he been reading Plato
well I thought this is eerily familiar
well he sounds just like because he was
channeling calacles yeah because okay
exactly I thought these guys are like do
you know calculus and uh the the
gorgeous yeah uh says I don't know if
you noticed that when you read it right
because it's the sort of thing that when
you're studying philosophy you might not
even might not even get mentioned but if
you look closely why he says to Socrates
repeatedly is you're not a real man
right like he says repeatedly you're a
boy real men and he also says he sounds
like me too because he says this is
what's this is what slaves think yeah he
says you're like a boy philosophy is for
kids real men don't do that real men are
superior they're powerful they learn how
to influence other people yeah play and
control them and the laws that you're
talking about are your conception of
social justice is a conspiracy of the
week to try and keep that in the strong
and what you're seeing in a way with
those guys it's all about the oligarchy
and the the kind of the the Old Guard
like the nobility
um who come from this kind of Bronze Age
aristocratic culture trying to hang on
to power
lay and rationalize it so they're
struggling a couple times I think with
the Democracy right and they say we're
Aristocrats we're stronger and smarter
and richer and more powerful why should
we have to follow Euro laws yeah like
why shouldn't we just take whatever we
want from you you guys are our inferiors
we should be allowed to treat user in
few years well we should be the ones
making the laws up if we took control of
the city we'd be reading the laws
ourselves and tyrants just make up
whatever the laws they want like and the
only reason that we have to follow your
laws is because you've you've had the
kind of slave uprising like the new
common people because of Pericles right
yeah I've got the vault
right and now you're conspiring because
there's more of you
like it's like a slave revolt or
something yeah like this Indonesian
sense like you were saying yeah there's
loads of you and you're just banding
banding together and that's where you
get your laws and your Authority from
but it goes against nature like because
by Nature like the alpha male
dominates the pack you know you'll
notice they keep coming back
right I see that I've been here
the alpha you're naturally in charge and
all you know yeah
and I I nature Aristocrats are stronger
and Superior and they should dominate he
doesn't know what an alpha male is but
if he did of 100
yeah yeah he just said that that's what
he meant right he said just as in nature
like you know the noble unnaturally
stronger and Superior and bear in every
way yeah and you guys have just tricked
us into acting like like the week you
know and we should be we should be
taking everything and but to regain that
we need rhetoric wait we need to learn
the power of influence over the week in
order to get our control back
um so I really I think the problem in
modern society is
pretty much the same problem the young
people drink from a veritable fire hose
of self-improvement advice from
influencers who are really just in it
for themselves yeah have never studied
psychology or philosophy like Socrates
says in the gorgeous like what do you
guys study
do you have you guys so you guys want to
influence the the city have you studied
the nature of Justice have you seen
economic no no we haven't studied that
what we study is how to influence people
but influence them to do what I don't
know whether we feel like yeah whatever
we feel like right and he said but
that's not what a leader is a leader is
someone that knows what is healthy
you know for the city
um these guys don't know what's healthy
psychologically
for the the people that are signing up
for the self-improvement courses and
reading the books and stuff like that
all they know is that they figure out
how to get your attention and persuade
you to follow their advice right that's
what they're good at their influencers
the clue is in the name yeah basically
right and they'll say whatever gets the
most likes just as an ancient world this
office would say whatever gets the most
votes in the assembly or you know gets
the biggest Round of Applause why when
they're giving a lecture in the uh the
gymnasiums right same to do but so I
think that's the problem that people are
facing is the same kind of problem
um we mentioned I mean we we started off
we were talking about some of the
problems and risks associated with
different psychological practices yeah
yeah and I I'd say it's there's this
other philosophy problem of you know is
this a clinical
situation do we need to do a risk
assessment or or not but I wanted to
kind of back up and say look obviously
short answer
if someone has a mental health problem
and they're vulnerable
then they have to be cautious about
causing themselves to triggers why they
could exacerbate a problem
so of course if you're suicidal and
depressed and you visualize your own
grave like there's you have to be
careful about doing that yeah you might
not be able to take it Epictetus gives
the best advice but that the stoics
understood it on the model of choosing a
sparring partner when he's talking he
says how does the bull know that it can
toss a line on its owns
um which which bulls do right yeah right
but what his point is that it's only the
alpha male the strongest bulls that can
do that the calves like are packed off
by the the weakest members of the hills
are picked off by the lines right yeah
he says how do you know that you can do
that through experience
through trial and error you can take
things gradually right and over time you
figure out how strong you are how
capable you are of enduring different
things but if you if you're wrestling
um you figure out what guys can beat you
and what guys you can be and you choose
sparring partners somewhere in between
if you don't pick something that's too
easy you need to pick someone that's too
difficult so you know this this brings
up a common issue that I've seen happen
lots and lots of times with people who
get interested in stoicism are really
any form of you know let's call it
systematic personal Improvement that's
got some substantive basis a lot of
people want to like jump in right away
I'm going to do as much of this as
possible because it's going to totally
change my life and then of course they
fail they get discouraged then they a
lot of them leave it behind or they
blame the the system itself so I mean
you know they went to see a therapist
yeah a good comments if therapists might
say to them like could it being that
you're exhibiting a tape of all or
nothing thinking that sets you yeah and
this is actually one of your symptoms
why and that actually this is typical of
people that suffer from problems such as
depression and Social Anxiety that they
apply rigid high standards for
performance to themselves and there are
often other people yeah and thereby say
unrealistic goals and set themselves up
for failure and you'd be better setting
more modest goals and working on them
more consistently in order to achieve
success what you're going to do like is
in way you know for Perfection yeah like
fail and then become depressed yeah
you know um you see this in ancient
philosophy but also in uh religious
texts you know talking about the same
sort of thing John Cassian is a great
example you know where he um first of
all he thinks that you can't one person
can't have the whole of the virtues
you're lucky if you can cultivate one
virtue you know so he's he's very big on
on being realistic about that but he
also talks about this because I guess it
was a problem with monks you know he's
mostly about about early monasticism
this like you're saying all or nothing
I'm gonna totally change my life and
he's like no no no you got to be really
careful with this because
um you're you know you're gonna you're
gonna fail a whole bunch of times and
you just need to like find something
that you can work on and you can't work
on he tells he says explicitly you can't
work on all of your bad dispositions at
once that that's crazy talk you know
pick one of them only one and only work
on that until you at least get it in
decent shape and then you can start
thinking about other stuff you know one
of one of the advantages of doing
therapy is you get to listen to a lot of
clients yeah and yeah so one of the
things that the therapists and
counselors could just do based on their
experiences they'll go this that just
sounds like stuff that clients say at
the beginning of like so sometimes I'll
tune in yeah like self-help guys and
they'll be talking about hyping up you
know like this kind of perfectionist
Mastery modeling and stuff and I think
that sounds like every depressed client
I've ever seen that's what they're like
when they come in the like the
assessment and so you can't you know
sets alarm bells ringing you go like
that that's how people talk
who are suffering from psychological
problems and those other things that you
recognize you go that this is typically
how people think this is the way that
people think I wanted to write a book
there used to be there was this book
there was a TV program called What Not
to Wear
oh I remember that yeah I wanted to
write a book called what not to think
okay right because would it would it
have a similar kind of structure to it
where like a couple experts come in and
they go through your your wardrobe up in
your head and they're like no I get rid
of this this is yeah that's just
straight that's amazing that whole
philosophy is junk right but they you
see in in practice I'm being blood but
you know and you you see people with
certain attitudes philosophies rules
that they follow and yet this is typical
of people who generalized anxiety that's
typical people who will see deers
typical we're depressed clients and it
it was one of the things you benefit
most from as a therapist because then
you think geez I better watch that I
don't start talking like that because
look where it got those guys right and
then you tune into turn on YouTube or
whatever and you know I there's all
people of the internet that talk like
that kind of advising the Youth of today
on
you know and it's always been us like
it's kind of it should be obvious
sometimes that it's uh bad advice I mean
look at this guy with these Bugattis and
stuff right yeah as if
like you'd think is it not self-evident
that that isn't uh a healthy uh
sustainable by way of you know a
philosophy of Life yeah
um is it not obviously absurd
but it's a sign of desperation in a way
like that people would latch on to that
because you'd think surely they can see
you know the it's facile and you know
not everybody can have a load of sports
cars and even if they did it's probably
not going to make most people all that
happy yeah like just to own a load of
stuff like owning a lot of stuff doesn't
necessarily make you happy there's a big
Revelation from the whole history of
Western Philosophy by some that way well
and and also once you've got the stuff
you've got a news tactic you worry more
about it I mean one of the one of the
thematics that runs throughout
um all sorts of virtue ethics Traditions
is the realization that money is
supposed to you know getting money is
supposed to provide us with security but
as soon as you've got it if you haven't
got your your motivations and your
priorities set up right you are more
miserable being rich than you were being
poor because now you got to worry about
somebody else coming along to take your
money or inflation erotic yeah yeah
you've got a whole bunch of like of new
worries about it well I I before I
forget there's a couple other things I
should mention okay because people ask
about them so
I've done psychological techniques so
this idea of premeditation Allure it's a
great idea right yeah
so first of all I'll say what not to do
and then I'll say you know some
potential benefits that people might
Overlook
um right the main thing because so the
stoics just take it for granted that
this is the thing that you might do they
don't ever say Marcus are really is no
point sits down and says let me just
explain the protocol to you guys
like he just kind of mentions off the
cuff as it were in this same car it's
really useful to do this how do you do
it right they don't really explain
generally in therapy what we would
assume is you
you probably don't want to it depending
on how vulnerable you are particularly
if you are prone to something like panic
attacks or other mental health problems
like you might want to set graduated
group goals where you construct what we
sometimes call a hierarchy of situations
right so it might be that you start in
the middle of that hierarchy usually we
do try and get people to start as close
to the top as they can so it's a
hierarchy of say 10 situations that make
you anxious perhaps but ranked with the
most severe at the top
and then going down and so usually I'd
say to applying what how high up on that
list do you think you could begin
and we can discuss what would be
manageable for them right if they're
quite a robust individual and they don't
have panic attacks or PTSD or anything
like that I'd encourage them to start
pretty high up right maybe even at the
top but if they do have panic attacks
Mega phobia they've got PTSD or the
suicidal and depressed like they might
want to start like halfway down the last
or maybe even at the bottom of it with
your baby steps perhaps like or at least
start you know something that's more
moderate it's not gonna the key is is it
gonna be overwhelming for you to
visualize this thing the students want
us to visualize dying in poverty and
losing our loved ones and stuff so that
might be too much for some people right
oh yeah so you pick something that's
manageable that's a challenge but isn't
overwhelming right
um and then the key variable honestly is
duration like broadly speaking it's if
you visualize something that provokes
anxiety or you put yourself physically
in the presence of it yeah right
um so you'll have a very strong urge to
escape the situation right now what the
risk here is that if you terminate the
exposure by which I mean uh you
visualize something makes you anxious
and then within a minute you bail
there's a possible you're probably not
going to benefit from that there's also
a possibility you're actually hating
your sensitization to it so make you
worse right if you do that so no one
ever markets release never mentions that
he doesn't say or visualize yourself
dying but you know don't just do it for
like a minute and then build because if
you keep doing that you might actually
make yourself even worse than you were
right right so you have to do it for
longer than you would normally want to
do it and what that feels like
subjectively for the most majority of
people is that you're doing it until it
becomes pretty boring right so if you
can get bored visualizing your own death
it's kind of boring doing this and then
you think well isn't it kind of
interesting that it's become boring when
it used to be quite worrisome for you
yeah so that you could see habituation
sometimes emotional habituation does
feel like getting bored thinking about
something right if you're bored your
anxiety is probably wearing off right
right right so another way we would do
it is we would re-anxiety and we should
say you should maintain the exposure
until it's decreased
roughly to about
one-third or less of what the original
peak level was so from sake of argument
let's say you set it as a hundred
percent so I go on a room and it's full
of snails and I've got snail phobia or
whatever Worm for worm phobia is
actually really common like you're in a
room full of worms in the camera right
um
surrender remember ones spiders whatever
like 100 anxiety you're gonna wait stay
there until it's below is a rough rule
of thumb below about 30 percent okay
like thereabouts ideally as a therapist
that's what I would I would continue
until the client was reporting that it's
about 30 percent maybe 35 percent
ideally we get it then zero right
usually that's impossible and you'll get
it down five percent or ten percent or
something like that but you don't really
want to store until definitely from 100
you'd want that below 50 right ideally
below about 30 or 40 and then you can go
okay that says done for today
yeah yeah guess what we're going to do
next week same thing right until you get
bored with it and yeah it doesn't bother
you anymore right and you're permanently
habituated like to snails or blood or
whatever is it yet phobia for so the
stoics don't
tell us that it has to be prolonged
enough and if you break off how long
does that take for visualization it's
probably going to be roughly 10 or 15
minutes or something like that maybe
yeah you might want to do it for a bit
it varies quite a lot the main thing is
you keep track of some kind of uh
measure whereby you can engage the
progress you've made now that said
I was going to say to you visualization
one of the things I love so much about
it is that if you just visualize bad
stuff right there's actually by my count
broadly speaking maybe half a dozen
different psychological processes that
might benefit you
and some there are studies going back to
the 1960s that sure they often happen
spontaneously okay
um but if you tell someone
that these things happen spontaneously
they could do them some of them
deliberately and and they become more
likely to happen because people are
watching out for them let me explain so
if you if I tell a client usually what
happens is your heart rate will go down
and it takes and I draw them a diagram
and I show them a video of someone else
out like now you're making it more
likely that it's going to happen because
yeah yeah expectation has increased the
modeling what they saw but also they're
reassured and also they're recognizing
the signs of it beginning to happen in
themselves which gives them some corn
for this right
um
so if we talk about emotional
habituation that's the most robust thing
you'd expect that to happen there are
some hints of that one of esop's fables
is based around this idea the fortune
the lion
so there's a fox both good roots and it
sees a lion and it yeah it freaks out
and runs away but it goes back the next
day and he's behind the bishop looks at
the lion and so it becomes scared but
not as much as the day before and then
the third day goes back to Forest and it
sees the line and it's anxious but it
manages to walk up to the line in that
and it like becomes his friend like so
that whole point of that is this idea
that repeated prolonged exposure you
know and you can find this passage in
Plutarch I think and there might be
things in the story it's that vaguely
hint at this so there was some awareness
of this idea in in the ancient world I
believe now that happens other things
that happen
first of all your appraisal of well
first of all cognitive distancing will
happen so some cognitive stuff happens
yeah
um I bet Jason's almost like a
physiological process it happens in
animals you can train a horse through a
repeated prolonged exposure to overcome
anxiety to life in response to loud
noises yeah you know even quite simple
animals show this phenomenon
um cognitive distancing so just like
Epictetus says uh if you can realize
that it's not things that upset you but
your opinions about it that realization
in itself we now know is one of the most
powerful mechanisms in modern
Psychotherapy we call it verbal
diffusion or cognitive distancing and
there's been a lot of research interest
in it over the past
20 odd years
um it's revolutionized Psychotherapy in
some ways
and if you can
observe your own beliefs and notice how
they're influencing your emotions first
of all what tends to happen is it
dilutes the intensity of the emotion so
noticing that it's your beliefs that
cause the anxiety when you're
visualizing something so there's two
things the others yeah yeah you're
visualizing the car but then you're
maybe having thoughts like oh my God
this is awful I'm not going to be able
to cope with it people are going to look
at me and it's going to be embarrassing
yeah so you've got like a bunch of
anxiety provoking thoughts right and if
you can step back and go you know it's
no wonder that I feel anxious when I
keep telling myself all this stuff and
some of it might not even be true like
but it's those things I'm telling myself
for contributing to the anxiety so by
repeated by visualizing the situation
you give yourself more opportunity to
notice the dynamic of what's going on
with your cognition and to gain
cognitive distance from it
now the second thing that happens I
think is actually more important two
things happen when you gain cognitive
distance one it will tend to reduce the
intensity of the initial emotion and
that's what most people notice but
something else that happens I think is
actually more important okay so overlaps
more with behavior you gain cognitive
flexibility so if you notice that your
thoughts are causing your emotions you
become more capable of adopting
alternate perspectives
so you can think you can start to think
to yourself
um maybe there are positive aspects to
this like perhaps if I persevered with
that I'd become more confident in
general way and better manage my
emotions in other situations and that
can help me in other words like so you
start to tell yourself other ways of
looking at the situation and we call
that cognitive flexibility you can shift
between different ways of looking at it
people who can do that are better at
problem solving
right there it's a creative process in a
way like they start a few things
differently so that ability to see
things from more angles rather than just
being locked into one way of judging and
looking the situation is liberating and
it makes you better that's a bit more
complex problem solving it's not going
to work out better for you in the long
run so that's two things emotional
habituation cognitive distancing
the other thing that then happens is you
change your threat appraisal
um so
you'll begin to sometimes cognitive
therapists might call us by different
names but sometimes called it reality
testing
um you start to think you start to
question so first of all you all you've
done initially is just notice that your
beliefs are causing your emotions now
what you're going to do is start
questioning whether those beliefs are
actually true or false yeah yeah so you
might say say with anxiety anxiety the
cognitive model of anxiety is it's an
exaggerated appraisal of the probability
and severity of threat and uh and under
appraisal your coping ability right so
you might start to first of all
reappraise a threat so you might go
maybe it's not that likely that I'm
going to lose my job you might represent
severity you might go even if it did
lose my job maybe it wouldn't actually
be the end of the world yeah right so
there's two uh things that you might
start to appraise differently by
visualizing the situation patiently if
you live for long enough you may might
start to think maybe I'm not viewing
this realistically like maybe I'm
exaggerating the probability of it maybe
I'm just exaggerating severity of it
right now you might we appreciate your
coping ability you might start to think
hey
maybe I'm more able to cope with this
maybe there are people that helped me
maybe I've got resources I can tap into
um you know maybe I can the other people
I've seen deal with a situation that
could copy or model their behavior so
generally all these things if you don't
really appraisal or your coping ability
so you become for to put it very simply
more confident about dealing with the
situation confidence will tend to reduce
your distressing your anxiety confidence
comes from lots of ingredients but it
might come from identifying multiple
options from rehearsing them from
observing other people and modeling
their behavior but the main thing is
you'll start to question and reappraise
your you'll go from I can't handle this
to maybe there are ways I could handle
this like and then that starts to lead
from the cognition into the behavior so
by visualizing things the anxiety will
wear off you'll start to notice how your
beliefs are affecting your emotions
you'll begin to reappraise another
probability of severity of threat you
begin to reappraise your coping ability
you're now going to engage in Creative
problem solving so you'll start to think
hang on I could do this I could do that
like and the longer you spend
visualizing something and going through
it in your mind the more you'll think
and why don't I just do this so you'll
naturally engage your problem-solving
ability right
next
your rehearse
um coping strategies so you might think
okay I could I'd be assertive with my
boss that'd be a way of dealing with
this situation you think I could say XYZ
um but I'm still a bit unsure about
doing it because I've never done that
before well you visualize it
and you might go through the steps
repeatedly so by doing that the steps
become more familiar your confidence
increases but also you're more able to
actually do it in practice the behavior
becomes more skilled and more automatic
because you've rehearsed it many times
in your imagination
so there are changes uh emotional
cognitive behavioral level of a number
of different varieties all of these
things potentially stem I'll tell you
here's one of my favorite studies right
in the 1960s behavior therapy really
began properly with a gecko a South
African researcher that moved to America
called Joseph volpi and he developed a
technique called systematic
desensitization now a lot of things that
Psychotherapy have to do with cats for
some weird reason right and vulping now
it's not just you use economics not just
me okay no it's just cats are a
recurring theme so Volpe had a lot of
caps and you know so trigger warning for
the audience right he'll executed the
cats but no and apparently he claimed in
a way that wasn't actually painful right
it just kind of startled them right so
he did that because cats are really easy
to start so he could have just made a
loud noise or something actually and it
would probably have a similar effect
yeah right they gave them a very mild
electric shock because he wanted to
induce and then remove
phobia
so he gave them a short trigger of the
start to reflex after bow the cats
wouldn't go in the room let alone go in
the cage and so Volpe said well what
happens if we gradually re-expose them
to the room but in just a physiological
response that's antagonistic to anxiety
repeatedly and he thought well let's try
that theoretically that should work in
terms of Behavioral psychology what's
the response eating right is animals
can't normally freak out and eat at the
same time humans seem to do that
sometimes but generally if an animal's
freaking out it stops eating yeah right
and it will resume eating when it feels
safe right so volpis would bring the cat
as close as he could down the corridor
and then he'd give it some treats a way
for it to come down they bring a little
bit closer on the cat they're getting
nervous as they've got closer we're
gonna give it some treats some called
Common Sense training and he said after
a while he could do by using this
technique he could eliminate the anxiety
and get the cat to happily say in the
cage and eat the food again as if
nothing had happened right yeah and he
said well let's do this for humans right
and he thought whoa I can't electric
humans but what we could do actually
they tried to play but generally
speaking it's a bad idea so he found
people that had phobias and other
anxiety disorders and he thought I can't
just give him fishy treats like I'm
gonna have to figure out what candy yeah
if you try to give them a candy but it
seems doesn't quite seem right yeah it
doesn't have the motivational Force
right what I'm gonna do is teach them a
technique that was already established
by a professor of physiology at Harvard
Medical School called Edmund Jacobson
which we call progressive muscle
relaxation so Jacobson had already done
a lot of research on physiology of
muscle relaxation
uh going back decades and decades and
Bobby said I'm going to take that
technique it's evidence-based it's
science-based was we've got all sorts of
measurements on it I trained people in
it and I'm going to get them to
repeatedly visualize the things that
trigger the phobia while they relax
every muscle in their body I'll train
them to write some muscles first and
then I'll get them to do it while they
repeatedly visualize things going up
this hierarchy of exposure that
mentioned earlier right until they've
desensitized he called to everything by
combining relaxation with exposure to
the field situation now we now know
um it's unnecessary to do the relaxation
part people prefer doing it but actually
we don't need to induce relaxation
because as long as you
um and what Volpe had brought the cat
down the corridor until it was refused
to go any further and he just waited
long enough the anxiety would have
repeated naturally anyway it would have
taken longer than it through feeding
them but it's a more organic process
um and it would mean for example you
don't feel that you're dependent on
relaxation as a coping strategy yeah you
don't have to go to the trouble of
teaching it as a skill so it's a more
primitive it's a simpler it's more
organic it's a physiological process
just to do exposure and but relaxation
can sometimes be used
that approves cons to using it but
sometimes that can be used as a a way of
kind of speeding up or accelerating the
the process but here's the research
study that I like there are a couple
actually that point to that same
conclusion Volpe
became a kind of cause celebrity of uh
early behavior therapy and researchers
observed them through a one-way mirror
doing his therapy with clients and they
noticed that Volpe didn't uh debrief his
clients much he was very successful and
he was good he was happy to replicate
this like in a laboratory setting right
unlike Friday and psychoanalysis VOC is
like I could come to your University and
I can do this in a psychology lab if you
want if you watch me do this video right
you could wire them up to heart rate
monitor what we're doing it let's see if
Freud do that
that's just not conceivable with their
approach but this approach we can do
hard research on right yeah um
we can do use more concrete measures and
look at more observation more controlled
experiments and so people observed them
and they thought well first of all he's
not debriefing these clients as much as
as he could and so some of the
researchers interviewed the clients
and they said
something that valky never really asked
them they said what was going on in your
head
when you were relaxing and picturing
blood or a plane crash or spiders or
whatever can be a phobia
and they said all sorts of different
things they said a lot of things that we
were just talking about so the
relaxation helped them but they also
said well I started to think to myself
maybe spiders aren't really as scary as
I thought they were and I started to
kind of say to myself well they're
probably more scared of me than I'm a
them and so they started to reappraise
the threat they started to say to
themselves things like you know maybe I
could do that so I could do that to
co-op and become more confident they
started to come up with possible
solutions to particularly social
problems so they say if they had anxiety
about making a mistake in a presentation
social anxiety
and they might say well visualize and
give them a talk and forget my words and
I just stare at the audience and they're
all staring laughing at me and I
suddenly thought I could make a joke out
of this yeah so you know they're problem
solving right they're coming up with
possible solutions by creative
brainstorming almost
um
and so they'd start to engage in these
cognitive and behavioral rehearsal
things and I hope you never knew they
were doing that because he didn't ask
them
yeah he made the basic error of not
asking the client what was going on in
their head
right he just sat there and got into the
lights the muscles and said yeah I feel
better and they're like yeah sure and he
was like see it works and but it's like
they opened the black box and the
interviewers were like what was going on
in your head when he was doing that and
they said not just relaxation but these
other things as well and it hadn't
really a couple that some of these other
things might be contributing to the
therapeutic outcomes so in the same way
with stoicism I think with the the
stoics have some awareness of emotional
habituation they couldn't know but I
think
well they're also aiming to do is to
apply their philosophy
to the principles of the philosophy to
the death and poverty in Exile that
they're visualizing yeah
um and so there are that's cognitive
distancing so if Epictetus is
visualizing his own death or the death
of his children I must imagine at some
level what he's really going on in his
mind is he's thinking it's not things
that upset us but rather her opinions
about them
um and he's also maybe visualizing her
Sage with Cork and modeling that in his
imagination of well he's doing this so
all of these stoic techniques and
principles are probably being activated
during premenital you know maybe
something deliberately maybe something
yeah automatically that's an interesting
point one one of the things I keep
saying is sort of like Socrates where
people are probably getting sick of
hearing it from me is that
um you know people are stoicism is this
one thing and you need to learn this
it's you know usually the dichotomy of
control or something like that then I'll
say no no it's it's a vast system of
interconnected things and they work
better when they're actually connected
up with each other so you have to read
the texts and obviously yes you have to
do practices but you know you kind of
need to like go through the things and
then I said by the way Seneca says this
in letter 33 you know uh when he's being
asked for sound bites
um and so you know what you're saying
there is that in a certain way like I
mean I wonder if we could say this about
multiple practices that if somebody is
doing them well you know they've become
skilled at doing that practice it's sort
of reaching out into the domains of the
other practices as well so inevitably
especially if you have an education so
what this makes me think of is I used to
um be very interested in Buddhism
at University when I did my Philosophy
degree I took you take options in your
first second year whatever I studied in
a history of uh Indian religions and the
theology faculty and uh I studied
history of Hinduism and Buddhism
at University when I was doing
philosophy and I used to go to business
Retreats and stuff and I met a bit this
month once and he was explaining
business mindfulness to me and he was
saying you just said to pay attention to
your breathing yeah yeah and you know
you're not meant to really do that much
you just imagine intrusive thoughts as
if they're close passing across the sky
and he said of course what people
westerners particular maybe don't really
our late persons don't appreciate it is
that when a Buddhist monk does this
they've spent years studying Buddhist
psychological theories and theories of
uh unhealthy thoughts and desires and so
they have all of that knowledge at the
back of the mind when they're practicing
mindfulness so they know what sort of
thoughts to look out for
they are they're not trying to interpret
the thoughts and stuff but they have
that knowledge in the mind that's
practicing made us and so you might sit
and discuss Buddhist citras they explain
different types of desires or different
types of unhealthy thoughts and then you
go off and do your mindfulness
meditation like have no layer why so you
you have an understanding of psychology
that informs the mindfulness practice
and it's the same in stoicism that that
whole system of philosophy is activated
when you're doing the visualization or
when you're okay
yeah I like that term activated you know
yeah it's part of your perspective
well you you can't switch off
like it's there informing even if you're
not having a conversation with yourself
about her it shapes your perception
of what's going on
yeah
that's a good way to put it
um before we we end I did want to
um get you to talk a little bit about
the book that used you said it was a new
book but not really a new book because
you've been thinking about it and
working on it for quite a long time
and it's specifically about Socrates
yeah it's all about so please
well
I thought
I got frustrated with the the Socrates
because I thought
you know if you again if you study a
subject for a long time you have these
odd recurring thoughts and feelings
about it yeah so one of them was
um
there's a book called subseason love
that came out recently by Armand de
Janeiro who uh from my with his name uh
but they
he he says that we could write a
biography of socrates's Youth and no
one's ever really properly attempted it
and he has a bit of a Gore sketching an
outline over
and the problem with Socrates is that
some of our sources are semi-fictional
yeah there's a debate among Scholars
about
it appears that some of the historical
details that Plato describes are are
implausible and contradictory and
um anachronistic and there's
contradictions between some of our
sources those ambiguities so so you know
the usual mess that you have when you
treat an ancient biography right by oh
geez and then there's huge annoying
walls are so and and the apology the
most
iconic famous
uh Socratic text that has the most
kind of impact on our perception as a
biography Plato emphasizes that the
pronouncement of the Oracle adelphy yeah
absolutely critical in launching
Socrates in his philosophical career and
he has this whole little story about it
we have no idea when that happened
uh we have no idea whether it happened
before or after other events and yeah
like so it's really annoying if you're
about your history and I've often
thought we shouldn't let that stop us
from telling a good story right so okay
if you're a biographer you think well we
can't tell a story because we we can't
really be sure that it happened this way
or you know the also I believe that
Plato
sometimes is described it's possible
that sometimes he's using canister
Dunhams and referring to real historical
figures sometimes obliquely maybe
there's an amalgam of them yeah for
example calacles
um we don't know as a real individual
from what I recall uh but certainly he's
a type of individual
and NATO's audience must have thought
calorie smellakies this guy sounds just
like the other famous did yeah yeah
right it's he sounds like this guy I
like one of the famous politicians that
everyone was complaining about stuff
like we know that guy he's just you know
you would today if you saw a play and it
was about a famous Republican politician
you'd be like well this guy just sounds
like a whole bunch of Republican
politicians yeah yeah yeah or a Democrat
or whatever like he falls into a type
um but we don't tend to read it that way
although surely his audience would and
then there's other famous enigmas like
for example diatima isn't referenced
ever again by anyone in any context like
but she plays a extremely I mean
Socrates actually implies in the
symposium
the very out pretty early on that is
dateable he says it was 10 years before
the plague yeah she was in Athens so
you've got some indication of chronology
there so be prettier relatively early in
his philosophical career
um and then he says he has this
conversation with her about love and he
says it just went like this and then she
does something that really resembles the
Socratic method in that little video
exactly yeah yeah are you implying that
she taught you
the first of the surprise method like
but you said in the apology that you got
the idea of that from the Oracle at
Delphi so there's some sort of clash
perhaps maybe there's ways that we could
resolve that a part of contradiction but
dear Timo is this is a fictional
character
it looks like we're told that she's from
Mountaineer and the peloponnese
which makes it sound like maybe she's a
real person but some authors have been
also she sounds a lot like aspers here
yeah yeah right and so some authors have
said does hence that she could be uh it
could be like a synonym or it could be
that he's really referring to ask your
other sources tell us that Socrates was
friends with this woman who
um is like a
a philosopher a sophist Jose yeah yeah
and so far as a woman could be
um in Greek society at that time and
she's quite associated with soccer
tissues
um she is the courtesan of Pericles and
I've got some sort of eventually marries
him
um
so
is this who plays who's talking about so
I thought it's frustrating right so
we've got this mess and it's just
annoying right yeah but if you look at
it you think there's a story there
that we can't tell because of the
shambles like this uncertainty unless
somebody is willing to just go do you
know what I don't care let's just
make a load of assumptions
to this and say I could be completely
wrong about this yeah yeah and just go
on and tell the story
like because I think there's a much
better story hidden than they are then
we Norm then as Apparent at first and so
I thought I'm gonna have a go at telling
a story I'm gonna have to make some
assumptions I'm gonna have to fill in
certain gaps I'm gonna have to
make certain assumptions about
chronology
um about individuals that could be
alluded to
um and it may be that the story I end up
telling is complete fiction and there's
no resemblance uh to actually happen but
I'll end up telling a plausible story
yeah about socrates's life and it's a
story about the development of this
philosophical technique okay uh and it
has all philosophy basically matures and
the reason I want to tell that story is
I think if you can tell that story in a
compelling way
those have to be more concise than
Plato's dialogues modern readers would
think I get it I get the point of the
gorgeous I get the point of the
protagonist there's some quite simple
points some of the arguments are
actually relatively simple but Plato
goes all over the place you know it
takes 20 or 30 pages to tell you
something that you probably could have
if you wanted to and there are reasons
why he does that but for a lot of modern
readers they just don't have the
patience
to kind of set through that right and I
I think there might be a briefer version
of it that loses something at original
but perhaps is much more accessible
to a lot of modern lay readers yeah I
mean it sounds to go back to something
you were saying just a few minutes ago
telling a plausible story but also
saying I could be wrong about this and
here's my assumptions it's sort of like
what so much
Socrates Plato scholarship has done
except without the signaling that they
could be rock yeah maybe that's maybe
that's true yeah
yeah
it's like the Socratic method as well
yeah when Socrates are saying you know
maybe this is how we could Define
courage right right so he's also saying
but it might not you know like I could
be I could be completely wrong about
this well but that happens
performatively right especially in the
early operatic dialogues where I mean
the courage is a great one because he's
talking with the military guy law case
right and they're like well we know what
the hell courage is because we've
exhibited it what the hell's wrong with
us that we can't actually give a logos
an account of it you know so I think
that's yeah that's a that's a really
and the interesting thing interesting
yeah is well first of all the example
that he gives of standing your ground is
obvious because just fighting a foulax
formation yeah oh yeah it's completely
it would be absolutely drummed into them
it's the main thing he's concerned about
is how do you train hot plates to remain
in information yeah and not put
themselves in other people at risk but
the real thing is although Socrates
immediately pixels and that really
easily so he said well what if you're in
the Cavalry yeah yeah right or what if
you're fighting a tactical Retreat right
then you're not remaining information
and standing in your ground doesn't make
sense then oh what about in civilian
life so it pulls up pretty easily yeah
nevertheless in the apology
yeah yeah uh and he seems to revert back
to this simple conception of Courage as
being about standing your ground yeah
yeah
because I don't think he's saying it's
entirely false he's not he's not he's
saying it's a an incomplete definition
but it's not completely wrong
um and then you know I think I I've come
to believe
that
Socrates
innocence in part I think
has to believe that wisdom consists in a
kind of cognitive skills yeah
um then the Socratic method itself
is part of what constitutes uh having
wisdom and the ability what we would
call to decognitive flexibility you know
as I mentioned earlier like this kind of
ability
to accept the definition but also kind
of see beyond it right right yeah and
realize that this definition actually
works in some situations but maybe it
doesn't work in other situations
yeah
um and to be able to not be to he talked
this is why he talks about being
suspicious about books and also why he
doesn't like he's suspicious about the
sophists because you know these kind of
ex-cathedral definitions of you know
they'll give you a lecture and then
they'll tell you
um this is what Justice says is what
courageous or whatever and Socrates is
the kind of guy who can't help but go
but surely that doesn't apply in this
situation yeah yeah
we were explaining to a bunch of kids
who were in in this philosophy club and
we were like little kids and really
Socrates is this kind of guy he just
can't help but go yes but to have a
thing he'd be like yeah courage is like
standing you're going it's okay yeah but
what if you're in the Cavalry yeah but
you know what if you're fighting a
retreat yeah but what about this what
about that and the kids will immediately
were like that that's exactly you know
we get that like that's what we're like
kids are like yeah right true yeah he
was like a kid listening to the sofas
and they're going
man is measurable things and stuff is
good yeah but like maybe if it's hot or
cold you can see if it feels hot to me
then as hot for me but if it feels to me
the it's going to rain tomorrow
why it doesn't really work in that so it
doesn't mean that yeah you know right so
this formula Works in some situations
but not in others and and I think that
leads them to the conclusion that you
know the sophists want to treat wisdom
like a product like you could go to
green grocer and buy a pound of onions
okay yeah yeah it goes to surface and
you can just buy wisdom and they'll just
tell you right believing this uh and
subsidies I think was to say you can't
really capture wisdom that easily anyway
and uh these variable formulas play a
part in it but you also have to be able
to see the limitations
if that is what he's implying that's
very resonant with modern research and
Psychotherapy
before we go around I'll just want to
tell you a piece of research okay
there's a study
um that has become very important to
third wave Psychotherapy and there are a
number of studies that raise questions
about what's sometimes called role
government behavior and this should be
very interesting to
uh tradition the
if you get two groups of individuals
and you get them to do an experiment
where they have to press a button
according to a certain pattern and if
they get it ready to get a reward get it
wrong maybe they get a little electric
shock or something like that right
um but they basically have to do this
for this Parliament right and in one
group you give them a piece of paper
with the instructions on it saying
do it three times then pause five
seconds and then once more and that's
the part to follow and they'll follow
that obviously and then you give another
group and you tell them they they have
to figure out by trial and error
so they can I get it wrong a few times
eventually maybe they had on the pattern
um maybe you give them some clues or
whatever but they basically figure out a
better trial and error learning okay
phase one experiment right phase two of
the experiment you change uh the
consequences
um so this pattern no longer works right
so you've got to figure out a variation
of it that works
um no if you go press about three times
pause press one where you get an
electric shock right well this is great
it's interesting so the group that you
give a piece of paper
like a sophist would teach you yeah a
definition of wisdom will carry on using
the strategy
even though they're getting punished for
doing it right yeah look for much longer
and the group that figured that out for
themselves through trial and error
learning will be much more likely to
adapt a and change and figure out the
new strategy more quickly now the reason
this is so important is that it's
obvious to behavioral psychologists in
particular that a lot of clients and
Psychotherapy
will tell you that they're using
behavioral strategies that maybe work in
some situations but are obviously not
working anymore and yet for some it's
puzzling that they keep using them yeah
and not abandoning them and adapting and
coming up with a new strategies right
and it may be in part because
they've learned these behaviors second
hand
verbally or they've been talked to them
by the parents are told to do them and
when they were at school or talk to them
in the army or whatever like and now
they're just following it legitly
whereas a guy that's had to figure out
for himself
like how to deal with somebody giving
him back chat or how to deal you know
with failing at something uh when he
finds that that strategy is no longer
working for him he's going to adapt more
quickly and figure out a new strategy
and the Socratic method reminds me of
that if you get if the sophists give you
some sort of formula for wisdom or
Justice or self-discipline yeah it might
you know say courage is standing your
ground right now why
I've memorized that I've got often
around that learned that at school right
I'm going to follow that strategy
obviously it doesn't work in some
situations as a definition of Justice
right but are you going to figure that
out quickly
and revise it or are you going to stick
rigidly with it even though it's not
yeah and just keep plowing away yeah
relentlessly right that would be really
unhealthy right it's better to be
flexible and adaptive and able to revise
yeah yeah well your definition as a rule
my a definition is a rule about how you
apply a concept like how you apply at
work
so the problem really comes down to the
problem of rigid rule government
Behavior right and not being sensitive
enough to accusing the environment to
adapt to them
yeah
now I I don't want to take us too long
but so we've got
somebody giving you a product right take
this go run with it and then you've got
sort of figuring things out on your own
but it strikes me that there would also
and then when we do this see we see this
with the people surrounding Socrates
right that there's also the interplay of
you know we've talked about this before
Let's uh think this out some more how
would this play out in this situation
the
the aspect of other other people
um you know learning from not just my
mistakes but seeing other people do dumb
things and
try not to do the same dumb thing so
what you've got there is the advantage
similar to cognitive distancing
we we are too close to our own thoughts
oh yeah yeah like to properly evaluate
them because we're like inside them
right yeah
um I mean it's easy well you see this is
you see this all the time if you're a
therapist or a coach you know you look
at your clients and you you kind of
think why are they thinking this and
telling themselves that it seems like a
you know it should be easy to say you
don't want to think that but yeah you
know you're depressed you think nobody
likes mirror but they hates me well we
you know that's about the generalization
but when you're in the grip of a thought
like that you're so engrossed in it you
don't have any perspective on it you
don't see it from the outside even
someone who suffers from clinical
depression if they looked at someone
else who is thinking that negatively
they would think geez that guy's being
overly negative
yeah they can they don't have enough
distance to take a step back yeah yeah
their own thoughts are biased you know
like we're too close we're in our biases
why so we don't really have the ability
to adopt perspective but we can see
other people doing it we could look at
uh also buy these
for example if you're Socrates do you
know one of the puzzles with my
biography and I I believe I know I've
got one possible I've got plausible
answers yeah the thing that bothered me
the most about Socrates is I thought you
could write about philosophies where you
don't really say that much about our
society is right but I thought you can
because everything we know suggests he
was absolutely Central to socrates's
understanding of himself like yeah
because he's was completely in love with
this guy
um and Plato hasn't been talking about
it it's pretty clear like he played a
huge role in his life and one of the
puzzles is why
why was so so fixated in the sky and the
ancient answer to it is just the socks
he's actually quite a sexual guy and he
was physically attracted to also by
these you know and as you think well
there's a moral of the story just that
sucks these is fallible like you know
nobody's perfect yeah so he fell for
this like you know incredibly handsome
young guy and they fell in love with I
think there's more to it than that
this is my version of a story right okay
and the apology Plato says that the
first thing Socrates did was go to the
wisest men that he could find he said he
went to a Statesman first he doesn't
pronounce his name right and then in the
protagoras Plato portrays Socrates
rushing to go and meet protagoras the
protagonist was referred to as the
wisest man alive so if I was Socrates
and I really took the Oracle seriously I
think protagoras is the guy that I
should go to first or someone like
pretty soon he's going to be talking
about list yeah yeah everyone says he's
the wisest man alive but he's the one
that I need to go and speak to of course
because we see that happening in the
protagoras right now I think the problem
what's going on lots of things about the
protagonist I think there's a problem
I think Socrates comes to realize by
talking to the surface
that
intrinsical because they claim to be
wise
they are defensive
and they're useless as interlocutors
because they're unwilling to be
completely open and honest with them and
to admit they're too invested in their
own reputation as soon as you say I'm
the wisest man alive you're now invested
in your reputation in a way that
prevents you from admitting when you're
wrong or even being completely honest
about your reasoning yeah yeah you're
intrinsically defensive I think he liked
alcobitis and he the one I'm gonna is
that softies over time seems to become
more interested in talking to Ordinary
People and then the apology he kind of
says that he says ordinary people seem
to me actually to have more wisdom than
the people that claim to be wise and the
great politicians and so on but
particularly he was known for talking to
the Youth of Athens why would he become
so interested in talking to the Youth of
Athens and also by these rather than
talking to the sophists and great
intellectuals and oracles he was
initially very drawn to these people I
realized
that
in order to have a really effective
interlocutor he needs somebody that's
going to be unashamed about making
mistakes but he needs somebody that's
going to be flexible and open-minded and
I think he found that more among young
people
than they all they didn't have a
reputation for wisdom to defend even our
sovieties had a reputation
um for aristocracy and courage but he
wasn't pretending to be a great
intellectual like you know were told
also by these worked like because you
know he became vulnerable in the
presence of Socrates right and he was
willing to admit that he was confused
and didn't understand and he came the
the other key thing that we see in the
theaters is some people ran away
and refused protagonist's kind of
portraits of avoiding certain being
possible selfies whereas other people
were talking that addictive and they
kept coming back for more I think
Socrates would naturally offend it's
more likely to be young people
like that found this addictive and came
back to it and he's a professional wise
men are gonna of course run a mile
why because how could they maintain
their reputation yeah uh and their
status if they keep hanging around with
this guy that keeps making them look
stupid you know that I guess that's one
of the simple enigmas about these is
that these guys are going to be out of a
job if they hang around with him too
much but the ones that are going to be
fighting with are the guys that I ever
claim to be a great intellectual to
begin with yeah like and I think you
know what we see happening is he
suddenly realizes that he has more to
gain I guess about the process
how to buy these has no idea
uh I've uh how to define justice
encourage and stuff but what he has it's
a value to Socrates is a willingness to
answer yeah very simply he's willing to
answer questions protagonist is
reluctant and the other surface are also
repeatedly shown as wanting to terminate
the conversation right wanted to launch
into speeches they're evasive in a way
that the youth are
that's my belief that makes sense I
think and I'm looking forward to seeing
that that book coming out
um how far along are you with it well
I've been two-thirds of the way oh right
you know like
um I try to approach an opposite to The
Graphic novel I think what that helped
what that does you know obviously what
helps with people might disagree people
might think it's ruined me as a right
but what I do is a kind of approach it
like I'm writing a graphic novel I guess
that's the other thing that forced me I
thought how could we ever write a
graphic novel about Socrates or make a
movie of his life unless we just go
right do you know what we're just gonna
have to bite the bullet yeah yeah and
make a lot of assumptions maybe make
certain betsark and combine these two
characters together like and then we've
got an amazing movie like yeah I mean
it's not as if we we have any
ER account that we can go back to anyway
so you know
that that that makes sense as a strategy
so well I think we've been talking now
for
over two hours
um this is really great uh very generous
on your part uh to give so much time and
thought to this
um
and uh people should check out Plato's
Academy there's all sorts of events
coming up consistently right
hahaha
for Christmas uh okay yeah because it's
very topical at Christmas
philosophy and death because yeah every
Christmas people go around
set her in the TV and they watch The
Muppets with Michael King and Charles
Dickens Christmas Carol and Ebenezer
Scrooge taking the Ghost of Christmas
Yet to Come to enter the future it's
easy Zone funeral it's kind of my mental
more eye contemplates his own mortality
like so contemplation of death
significance becomes socially oriented
Christmas yeah thanks to the Muppets and
the Muppet Christmas Carol yeah all
right well thanks so much for for coming
on Donald it's been great to catch up a
little bit too with what you're you're
doing you know I always enjoy our
conversations